seguramente ya están familiarizados con
la relación entre la multiplicación y la
división por ejemplo sabemos que 3 veces
6 es igual a 18 pero otra forma de
expresar esa misma relación es decir
casi 3 veces 6 es 18 entonces si inicio
con 18 y luego lo divido entre 3 eso es
igual a 6 como podríamos decir algo como
esto que 18 dividido entre 6 es igual a
ahora vamos a extender esta misma
relación entre la multiplicación y la
división a expresiones que involucran
fracciones por ejemplo si tuviera que
decirles que un cuarto dividido entre y
voy a codificar lo por colores dividido
entre 2 es igual a un octavo como
podríamos expresar esta relación usando
la multiplicación bueno si un cuarto
dividido entre 2 es igual a un octavo
esto quiere decir que un octavo por 2 es
igual a un cuarto permíteme escribir
esto así podemos escribir que un cuarto
es igual a un octavo por 2
y podríamos hacer otro ejemplo digamos
que voy caminando hacia ustedes en la
calle y digo oye tú 42 es igual a 7
dividido entre un sexto en el futuro
aprenderemos a calcular cosas como esta
pero con base en lo que vemos aquí como
podríamos expresar esta misma relación
entre 42 7 y un sexto pero con una
multiplicación pausa en el vídeo y
piensen en esto bueno si 42 es igual a 7
dividido entre un sexto eso significa
que 42 por un sexto es igual a 7
permítanme escribir esto esta es la
misma relación que 42 por un sexto es
igual a 7 ahora digamos que me acerco a
ustedes en la calle y les digo muy bien
les digo que un cuarto dividido entre 6
es igual a algún número que expresamos
como t entonces podemos reescribir esta
relación entre 146 y t pero en lugar de
usar la división usar la multiplicación
pausa en este vídeo y piensen en ello
entonces si un cuarto dividido entre 6
es igual a t con base en todos los
ejemplos que acabamos de ver eso
significa que si tomáramos t por 6
obtendríamos un cuarto podemos
escribirlo de esta manera t por 6 es
igual a un cuarto si esto no tiene
sentido quiero que piensen en cómo esta
relación es realmente la misma relación
que vimos aquí lo único nuevo aquí es
que en lugar de tener siempre números
enteros tenemos fracciones y
representamos algunos de los números con
letras